hi I'm Matt Welch editor-in-chief of
Reason magazine you know for decades now
people interested in free markets have
been talking about a glorious future of
private space exploration and travel
reason is that several cover stories
about including in 1981 a piece about
entrepreneurs versus NASA well as
current subscribers to reason can
already tell you we have a new issue out
in February that's here to tell you that
that glorious future a private space
travel is now our special space issue
profiles such entrepreneurs as Richard
Branson of Virgin Galactic Elon Musk of
SpaceX and other people who were trying
to replace the post Space Shuttle future
with interesting private initiatives we
also have a great piece from rand
simberg talking about space policy about
the Obama administration another piece
by Robert Zubrin that talks about dooley
overvaluing the lives of astronauts go
to reason.com backslash subscribe so
that next time around when a good issue
comes along it'll come in your mailbox
it's only 15 bucks a year we'll be
rolling out some of these stories
throughout the month at reason.com where
you can go to the newsstand and pick up
a copy for reason i'm matt wedge
you